haha the Joe Rogan experience met Adrian
Carmack at a bar in Texas which was
[ __ ] awesome
and and it was funny because he started
telling me like well if you guys are
gonna make it you know we were in
production on doom eternal he's like if
you guys gonna make a doom game here's
what we thought when we made doom and
everything he listed we were all like
that's what we think you know like he's
like we just did stuff that made us
laugh and made a smile I'm like that's
what we say you know like it was cool he
was super nice so it to me it's software
is kind of like Disney like they
invented a genre and we are part of the
new generation there and we have a
legacy to live up to like yeah it's the
it's a really special place to work a
tremendous amount of I don't want to say
pressure but we're all motivated
yeah well it's it's you know you're
working at the highest spot that's like
yeah if you go I mean if you think it's
like if it's rap you're at Death Row
Records you know I mean you you're like
at the highest spot and the coolest
thing is like the type of games that
they have always made just they they are
able to get away with things and a lot
of mainstream Triple A games struggle
with just because of how violent it is I
mean they are like again it's it's Evil
Dead 3 with a transformers budget like
who the [ __ ] gets to make that like you
know like we those the [ __ ] you see we
spent a shitload of time making that
stuff whereas like in a lot of
situations I've been in it's like yeah
we want to cut this dude in half like I
know a lot of my flat dude so do it
pretty fast you know like we're like
there are artists like craftsmen you
know working on the entrails like it
looks pretty good and we're and
literally the notes you're like I need
like the intestine to kind of like flap
a little when you get the thing off you
know like and it's how do you know if
you've crossed the line is there is
there ever been a time when you have a
scene and people like dial that back we
we actually tonally you know you say how
do you start the project it's it's kind
of like there's a fair amount of
brainstorming and the strength of any
creative team is at least for a game is
how you brainstorm with each other it's
the synergy in that room has to be good
you got to be selfless you got to show
up you got to be willing to support
other ideas other people's ideas as much
your own we have a [ __ ] amazing group
in that regard but tonally we try to
establish that to like look guys we're
not making saw we're not making hostel
it's not malicious it's not
to make you cringe and we actually cut
together a little video of like what we
thought violence wise was inappropriate
and tonally felt off and then we made
another video of what felt right and
that was Evil Dead 2 with like it's not
a slow trickle of blood out of a sliced
open wrist it is some dudes head came
off and Hawaiian Punch just starts
[ __ ] shooting out of his head you
know like that's really what it is like
it's cartoonish you know and it's
violence it goes so far that you because
the thing is you do this so much so
often I mean you are murdering demons
per minute like I don't know what it is
but it's [ __ ] crazy if it was
off-putting and realistic and kind of
like oof you'd be so turned off it'd be
sick like you didn't make you sick after
a while but so kind of weird we're
looking at it I don't think you're right
which doing is like super gory and
disgusting you think somehow or another
that will make you less sick well it was
more realistic and less bloody
oh for sure I mean that's totally we
could we could twist that where every
one of those is mean-spirited and really
off-putting for sure I mean I don't want
you to sell me some PR stuff to sort of
defend your game against people that are
anti violence because that's what it
sounds like what you're doing is super
bloody and disgusting and violent to say
that somehow know that that is less
off-putting
then less gory is pretty that's a
ridiculous argument I don't want you
using it here or anywhere else well it's
Joseph it is not I this is no PR this is
this is legit sounds like you've been
coached no no no like this this is my
message to the team I mean sincerely
like okay you're coaching them well
because they make the content so like
think of this alright I good I like this
because this is the [ __ ] truth so you
look at saw you look at torture porn
horror movies there they're cutting
achilles tendons with a [ __ ] exacto
knife and the dude is screaming in pain
and he's a person like this is gnarly
[ __ ] he doesn't look like he's having a
good time like verses on Evil Dead 2
when you lop off the head of that one
Grandma creature that comes up out of
the basement and like [ __ ] buckets of
blood start coming out of her head right
people cartoonish so like it's it's
critical Z row PR spin that is
we have to believe that because look
your design story is going to be exposed
to the to the consumer in two [ __ ]
seconds like they can see through your
[ __ ] in five seconds if they're like
dude you're trying to sell know like so
we have to have an honest good design
story that we can stand behind that is
true and that that is the truth I mean
we basically looked at like cartoons and
like make it over the top the animation
so every time here's a perfect example
every time you murder a Cacodemons which
is those flying balls you pull out their
eyeball what does it call the caca a kak
a demon a caca what's the CAC CAC CAC Oh
Oh CAC kids you have kids right I do
have three kids Kaakha Kaakha demon it's
a poopoo demon sure the so every time
you pull out his eyeball
you literally hear like oh I can't do it
but yeah like a like a funny cartoony
sound and that is absolutely intentional
to take the edge off what you're doing
because if it was more gruesome and
they're like it's the Exorcist versus
evil dead - those are totally two
completely different movies you know
House house was a movie that came out in
the 80s that was inspired by Evil Dead
that's like a [ __ ] comedy it made it
is a comedy and and it's a horror comedy
versus The Exorcist which is [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] amazing but really very
serious you know and that's that's how
we're able to do what we do okay stop
selling it I'm selling the violence
thing I get it I see what you're saying
what is this a caca demon that's a caki
demon it's caca that's poo poo looks
like poop they give like if you had a
demon [ __ ] that's what it would look
like like oh no tearing you up on the
way out
what is that an original one that is the
original caki demon from the original
doom yes oh cool so it's an updated
version of that but you know just more
graphically intense yes
[Applause]